hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his discussion
of justice in book 1 of on duties sister
reminds us of a very important fact
namely that there's more than one way to
do the wrong thing one way as he says is
to actually inflict wrong to do
injustice to somebody in that way by by
doing something active the other way can
happen through omission or failure or a
lack on our own part so Cicero tells us
that another way of doing wrong or
another kind of injustice occurs when we
don't protect others from injustice when
we have the capacity to do so that's a
very important provision there obviously
if we don't have any sort of real
capacity to intervene then it's not an
injustice on our part but if we see
somebody being bullied and we can
intervene and it's you know it might
cost us something but it's not gonna you
know lead us to be killed or something
like that
probably Cicero would say that we have a
duty to intervene and to fail to do so
is a serious problem he says that the
person who does
to prevent or oppose wrong if he can and
notice what he says here is just as
guilty of wrong as if he deserted his
parents or his friend or his country so
Cicero thinks that these these failures
to do the right thing to keep others
from doing the wrong thing or to protect
those who are vulnerable to harm or
injury or insult from from being harmed
is in fact quite culpable and so this is
something that we ought to take quite
seriously the other thing that he tells
us about this is a little bit later on
and it's kind of an inquiry as well why
do people fail in this duty to protect
those who are perhaps not only
vulnerable but for whom they're
responsible why do bosses not protect
their employees why do parents not
protect their children why did children
not protect their parents later on why
do we allow other people to to injure to
insult to to humiliate people who we
could protect so he gives us a whole
list of these and a lot of these you
know we might want to look at the Latin
terms a little bit he says that some
people do it out of a sort of reluctance
and he names three things that we might
be reluctant to have to engage with
they're they're kind of a pain for us we
we don't want to deal with that and the
word dealing with here in the Latin
translation there's a little bit more
old-fashioned that we have is to incur
right but but the Latin is so skipping
right to endure to have to deal with it
you have to you know ender is is another
word as well and so one of these is
hostility or hatred from other people
who's going to be hostile towards us
well if we if we keep those who are say
exploiting workers from exploiting those
workers if we
call attention to it we say you're doing
the wrong thing they may in fact get
angry with us they may resist us they
may say that we're the bad guys
similarly if we get in you know in
between somebody who's beating up
another person that person may turn on
us and try to attack us as well and so a
lot of people say I just don't want to
get involved it's not really my fight
it's not my thing but but the issue is
that they're they're really acting out
of a sense of fear fear of what is going
to happen to them
trouble you know some other issues may
come out of it should I get involved in
the fight between the big guy and the
little guy well but might I might get
messed up you know I just finished tying
it should I really get in there and
start you know duking it out with
someone I don't know you know if I had
like you know my gym clothes on then of
course I'd be in there fighting for them
well I mean we can come up with all
sorts of examples of that and so this is
when it calls labora right it takes work
on our part then we have expense well I
would get involved but I don't want to
pay for that and and you know if you
think about the opportunities that we
have in the West to make life better or
or simply to prevent wrong prevent harm
prevent you know unjust relations by
spending a little bit of money
I think cicero's discussion here
actually bears a lot of fruit he talks
in terms of what it is that we have to
pay what it is that we have to be
willing to shell out so that's one big
reason a sort of reluctance to deal with
these sorts of things he also talks
about you know he's using synonyms here
indifference
laziness sluggishness the last word
there is in there see how the word that
we get inertia from it means a
unwillingness to get up and do something
the first one is actually
negly giggle agencia
and and this can mean indifference it
can also mean a not caring you know
which you might say well that is being
indifferent but it is it's not caring
about what we ought to care about when
we say that somebody is negligent that's
what we have in mind they are negligent
by not caring about things that they
ought to care about it could be how
their appearance affects other people
right or it could be about what somebody
else saying or doing will you know what
sort of impact that will have on
somebody else and as Cicero of course
it's not saying that we have to like be
as you know people like to say these
days snow flakes about this or assume
that everybody else is snow flakes but
we know when certain lines have been
crossed if somebody is whoring another
person they probably shouldn't be doing
that if we see somebody bullying another
person whether physically or emotionally
verbally we know that that shouldn't be
going on if we see sexual harassment
taking place we shouldn't say that I
don't really care about that sort of
thing Cicero says we should be ready to
take whatever steps are necessary the
other one that he says that's really
interesting has to do with what we can
call preoccupation or self focus that
the Latin translation here has
self-interest but I think being focused
on one's own self is probably a better
way to talk about he says you know oh
Cappuccio is is is something that
intervenes preoccupation a little bit
later on he will talk about our own
business you know Nageotte sia as being
what it is so the things that preoccupy
us the things that we take is worthy of
doing can sometimes become impediments
to doing justice to actually protecting
people when we should we can say you
know I've got all this grading to do so
I can't really respond to this email
even though I probably should you know
I've kept my own work that I have to
concentrate on if I just do my own stuff
and I stick with my job this other stuff
will sort itself out or if it doesn't
it's not really my problem we might say
similarly about people within a family
you know if if you know that that your
child is having trouble in school and
you say well you know that's why I send
them to school so the school can handle
that sort of stuff I really have to
focus on the house or on my business or
on this other relationship over here
because because you know I've got to
make money in order to make this this
happen anyway so that's that's one thing
and then he talked about what we're
calling herself focus yeah that's the
oka pottsfield
studious as well the things that we are
zealous about the things that we take
care about you know if being a concert
violinist and putting in the hours and
hours of practice means that you have to
neglect your duties to protect other
people sister would say that's a problem
so we could go on and on with other
examples the last one that he talks
about that that's particularly
interesting is aversion to our fellow
human beings sometimes we just want to
be left the hell alone and we don't
really like spending time with these
other people he says oh do quote um
homing them swim right you know that we
don't like other other people and that
that allows us to to justify to
ourselves the fact that other people are
harming them they're jerks anyway they
got it coming to them we don't have to
be concerned with them now I do want to
point out one other thing back to this
this preoccupation this being concerned
with one's own projects one one's own
personal development cicero actually
criticized
other philosophers here he says there is
reason to fear that what Plato declares
of the philosophers may be inadequate
when he says that they are just because
they're busied with the pursuit of truth
and because they despise and count as no
not that which most men eagerly seek and
for which they are prone into battle
against each other for the death Plato
is saying look philosophers are great
because they're not going to get into
everybody else's business they're so
busy you know reading their books
thinking about the universe you know
writing books teaching classes doing all
that sort of stuff they stay out of
everybody else's hair Cicero thinks
maybe they should get into everybody
else's hair if they're so distracted by
their intellectual pursuits that they're
neglecting their human duties to protect
the weak the vulnerable the needy to not
allow injustice to be done to them then
they themselves appear to be unjust and
so he goes on and he says to secure one
sort of justice that's what they do but
they fall into the opposite injustice
hampered by their pursuit of learning
they leave to their fate those whom they
ought to defend he says Plato thinks
they won't even assume their civic
duties except under compulsion that this
is in fact what they ought to do so
Cicero is an advocate of what we call
the active life or a mixed life where
intellectual pursuits are coupled with
fulfilling duties in an active way and
that is going to include taking care of
other people and protecting them from
injustice failure to do so for any of
these motives makes one unjust
you